welcome to this video again a chit cube
tournament yeah after having done very
little of it for a long time I really
enjoy doing this again and I should
actually enter the tournament would be
helpful this is a bullet tournament so
um fast and furious da Vinci Toki's a
new d5 wasn't really planned but ok a
bit wrong timing but no no big issue
it's still a fairly normal position
whoopsie took with the bishop I didn't
expect that move and it's not a good
move but now it's tricky g4 was possible
but ok this is got a good position the
key file when I check me probably no no
big threat to cover so form no draw come
on
okay I can take here no better keep the
peace I strong or they're not i'm not
super quick IAM okay okay let's see what
happens to always get her to this bullet
mode first not a couple of minutes to do
that oops yeah obviously and what a
chess it's very difficult for me to do
any meaningful commentary that's some
really a bit too quick that at least
that I cannot do it i mean i know that
for instance kinks crashes sometimes
able to do that giving some sort of
comment commentary that make some sense
and bullet sir i cannot do it i need to
play and that's it it's really more from
ya enjoying some some fast action and
not taking things too seriously i still
try to play normal Jasmine in a wave but
then it's really difficult to do any
kind of threatening rubgy for now this
is nice maybe I get this in
yep gaap Queen takes i get f 3 with a
great attack I'm not sure what is
considering really King edge one okay
and this was possible initially as well
okay let's check the Queen again yeah
come on mate on g2 right yep yeah I'm
not winning so quickly here that's
always the additional thing that it's
not not see for additional thing that
needs to be done really winning quickly
come on maybe I get to get in something
on f7 here it's not such a bad move
anyway as I got h4 h5 and thus impact
dangerous really dangerous want to keep
the bishop here not give it up for a
night the bishop is very strong
can click here right and then on g6 yeah
come on bring h7 meat that was nice yeah
the bishop on c4 must really a super
strong piece difficult did you go to to
play this yeah like getting quick play
in there oops in the center looks looks
a bit like reversed French who installed
some active play possible here okay the
double attack h 2 and a 1
that is I made ok so here we go and
that's III is a decent pre move for move
to I know my deaf six should take but
sometimes this is easier for black to
play and bullet this time of positions
with this check made threats they can be
deadly oops come on ah those are long
loose and queen I don't want to give it
up here maybe the H poem which if I
maybe can take it I would really want to
calculate that cannot take huge pin no
Queen h4 is the threat queen h 527
checkmate so yeah I can take it I'm
still a mate okay ah five out of five
that's not too bad yeah let's
directly attack YTM oops yes f5
businesses so yeah it's more like a
bullet opening but you can can play it
it's not it's not totally totally bad
and the damn rather quickly get some
maturity going which is always maybe
it's moving the rook which is always
good in the bullet chest to get them get
activity yeah this Bishop is around
Ananias right should be able to get some
sort of attack a queen yo this is almost
trap game yeah let's get the mission
traded and then reach here with the
rocker yeah this is a mate made into a
mate in three can play rookie three nope
ok that's a good flow six out of six the
skies are being very relaxed with this
development okay not not falling for the
direct direct approach but it's still a
pretty good position
the f porn I should try to use the f
pawn opening up the position quickly
yeah it's a good pressure wow wow King
the eight oops roop d 1 and d 1 d 8 it's
not i'm not going to to end well piece
is a piece is a piece so but i'm down to
23 seconds that's not too great so do i
win deserve quickly maybe night here
oops I'll take it now maybe night
beehive here that's nice yep
the competition is actually not so bad
in the stone though many 2000 plus
players 2000s who I wanted to play I
wanted to play me five of course fy5
that's a bit much really maybe you can
take all this is not good not not
looking good okay maybe I get in bishop
is six so that i can actually castle
yeah
yeah that's that shouldn't shouldn't be
too bad yeah that's okay for luck that's
okay I know it's more than okay winning
the center poem 20 seconds 25 as well
that's nice we are picking up all kinds
of ponds him okay wowie 45 is for scary
one of those three scary my lips we
think oh I asked and can be costly yeah
just a pawn but it is a pond
I should plate f3m okay that's still
pretty pretty good position especially
now that I get this got my t5 check as
well Bishop two or three is good square
actually with this right with a chicken
then take f5 Wow dropping like that
flies or pieces here
the chick made yeah 9897 mate yep okay
my love I oh there's a bunch of guys
with seven out of seven she simply
happened one quick another quickly
enough a kingly fall right strong yeah
sometimes Oh No okay does this make some
sense what I'm doing probably not right
I want no one to the ship to f5 really
it's not very well coordinated in this
position Quincy aid was to prepare that
no Bishop h6 oops big boobs with no
night f5 is threatened and the noid
hangs
let f6 is also threat now I can take
with Luke you can take with the rook no
quit age 6 I wanted to play now Kim what
it is a stir Wow yeah this wasn't
suppose not really great and webelos of
a bad position in the way at least it
was tricky to play with that little time
okay I wanted somewhat simpler position
here 97 just a little little idea
winning the exchange and now d phi it
would be nice not here Queen I was
hanging I know you can actually take it
we didn't do it now this is nice again
yeah this should be relatively easy from
a technical point of view can the tick
can you tick yeah yeah oops didn't
really see that you can move it forward
yeah but still them exchange and
everything should be too much and how do
I actually make it this long this way I
guess still something a technical work
yeah this one loss and still irritates
me hey what the heck did i do them yeah
this should age six that I overlooked I
wasn't really great of course its lucky
sidelines
yeah so I I just have an endgame type or
at least a clean this middle game with
them an isolated pawn to play against
that's not bad not bad for starters I'm
down one to exchange stuff here is
giving me this pretty much without any
particular compensation yeah here I have
some coordination issue but I think he
just needs to retreat right yeah not
much that he could I really do I lets
you but he wants to go there anyway ah
stupid stuff what the heck that's
strange strange trade when I'm getting
that too active pieces
I'm actually head on the clock you
really ignored what was happening just
it just play moves very quickly okay
okay come on it's normally not a good
idea wow talk about gambit play having
some effect just winning in the house
IAM you know you he really was irritated
by this i guess just seven minutes left
so come on studied some wins IAM
yeah I want to alps want to open the f
file and then try to get the Queen over
that's not good it's always strong
attacking peace oh I should have taken
on a three with the rook it was a good
good opportunity destroying his peace
shield ass King King shelter she don't
not not a shield king of shelter this is
that this is also ok but always nice two
together now nice exchange sec I cannot
take it better I better cover see for
taking g5 it takes f 8 and wince my
queen but top-5 is just a good square
I'm threatening age six really the night
has no no good Square to go to I'm
covering f3h three and so on and this I
can take
yeah it wasn't very quick but I'm about
one game ahead so if it's all all ok
that's a very dangerous line that is
choosing here I white having lots of it
take attacking potential and I'm
probably not even playing the best
possible way but it's dangerous the way
I'm playing it I guess yeah let's just
open up the position here maybe h5 is a
move prevent him from castling both
sides so our King side is totally wacky
anyway but we are still I cannot cancel
and I'm just blundering the rogue ok
it's not taking it down Luke takes is so
nice for me how I should probably cover
the rook or keep the book he still
cannot cancel night maybe night to s six
cool age six is a bit of an inconvenient
threat down to ten seconds that's not
good the h-bomb h-bomb must save my day
and she's got a queen himself and this
is really unbelievable um but I one on
time okay yeah I really had no idea okay
what the squat you got left just push
the H porn had hoped for the best oh we
gonna again did whatever okay come on
I'll take it it's risky but I'm pretty
quick here with long castle so okay i
can check here and castle long should
really be mostly her piece of
oops I shouldn't have allowed that oh ok
ah Queen trade let's get the Queen
scripture to the screed the Queen's to
ride it ah maybe i can get here let's
let get me some attack here unlight is
also hanging can probably just take the
rest of the points iam not running into
a flock please ok come on let's let's
get the pawns running here ok wow this
guy is two points behind me m Osama one
what the heck so I probably need to win
your game here doing oops I don't like
that yeah I still need to need to win
that's the simple truth
right okay this is this is a a good
position in general a good position and
also a good position to to get a win in
I just need need to win this on 20
seconds it's probably enough and it's a
chocolate Wow very nice maybe this was
necessary it doesn't give me the points
oh the Sun will end it and at first okay
and well I will just strange end I mean
I won the game definitely but then the
tournament was over not quite sure but
as long as I keep them as long as I keep
their it's it's it's okay yes this one
came really badly again this was really
11 of game but the rest was quite quite
nice I think alright i hope you enjoyed
this tournament don't take them too
seriously too seriously just some some
some fun entertainment nothing nothing
to to be too too serious about yeah
thanks for watching